direct VPC egress on cloud run enables
you to send traffic through a VPC
Network without setting up a serverless
VPC access connector
it's easier to set up faster can handle
more traffic and has lower costs
this is a very exciting update to Cloud
run let's dive in to learn more
but let's take a step back why send
traffic to the VPC in the first place
top use cases for sending traffic to the
VPC include managing traffic with
firewall rules Network traffic
observability
getting static IPS for outbound requests
and connecting to internal IP addresses
and and that's the most common one
and here are some examples of resources
with an internal IP address that you
might want to connect to from cloud run
a memory store instance
a cloud SQL instance that doesn't have a
public IP
and a compute engine virtual machine or
services with an internal load balancer
on Google kubernetes engine
or on-premise resources
when you enable directvpc egress on a
cloud run service the cloud run
instances gets internal IP addresses on
the VPC Network
and this new interface can only be used
for TCP UDP egress
you can use it to create new connections
from the VPC Network back to the cloud
run instance think of this as a firewall
in front of the cloud run instance the
firewall allows outbound connections
only and no inbound could traffic from
the VPC
but the other interest path doesn't
change with directvc egress web requests
to the https endpoint of the cloud run
service are still routed to Cloud run
instances in the same way as before that
doesn't change
if you're watching this and you're
already familiar with serverless VPC
access connectors you might be confused
is directvc egress just another way of
doing the same thing but it has a
shorter name
well
yes but direct VPC egress has many
advantages over VPC connectors
to understand why let me tell you how
VPC connectors work
a VPC connector is a group of managed
connector instances
every connector instance gets an
internal IP address and it proxies
outbound connections from a cloud run
instance introducing an extra hop in a
network path
and VPC connectors are not paper use you
can think of connector instances as
fertile machines they are very much
alike in the sense that you are charged
for enabling them
even when they're idle
direct VPC egress doesn't need connector
instances which means you only play the
network charges this is why directvc
egress has lower costs
and it uses a new direct network path
and this New Path is faster and can
handle more traffic delivering lower
latency and higher throughput
so let's wrap up with directvc egress
you get fewer hops in a network path
enabling lower latency higher throughput
because of the new network path lower
costs and it's easier to set up and
manage
if you want to try it out today check
send traffic directly to a VPC when
configuring network access for your
Cloud run service
thanks for listening